so President Trump has a new nickname
for stormy Daniels and Elizabeth
Warren's native-american tale collapses
and Michael avenatti had a bad day and
now he's having a slightly better days
we will get into all the avenatti
related things I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is certainly the most entertaining
timeline I mean I don't know what
happened what black hole we fell through
to emerge from the other side where the
President of the United States is
calling a woman horseface he once had
sex with and she is insulting his
genitalia as a mushroom character from a
1997 video game but all I can say is I'm
very happy fell into this particular
black hole because it's deeply
interesting I have so much to say about
so many things today but first let's
talk about another podcast that you
should actually listen to there are
hundreds of thousands of legal cases in
litigation every day in the United
States court system most of them will
never reach the media's attention but
the ones that you know about well you
don't know as much as you think you do
which is why you ought to listen to a
podcast from andriy called legal wars
host Hill Harper gives you
behind-the-scenes access into some of
the most famous cases to have ever
graced America's courtrooms you'll hear
about influential cases that have
changed the face of America things like
the Rodney King trial or Anna Nicole
Smith's battle for her inheritance or
the takedown of the gossip site Gawker
go listen to legal Wars on Apple podcast
the first episode is about Hulk Hogan
versus Gawker which actually did change
the way media is done in the United
States this is a case in which Hogan
walked out of the courtroom with a
multi-million dollar settlement but you
don't know the whole story until you've
listened to legal Wars you can find
legal Wars on Apple podcasts wherever
you're listening to this or head over to
Wonder e dot F M / Ben that's wo ND ER y
FM slash been wondering if m / ben you
can go check out legal wars from honoré
other podcasts are awesome but this one
is particularly entertaining and I've
really enjoyed listening to it so go
check it out right now legal wars on
Apple podcast or at wonder if m / Ben
it's great you're gonna have fun
listening to it alright so did you think
that yesterday's news cycle was going to
be the pinnacle of insanity did you
think that we had really reached the
apex of crazy and hilarious with
Elizabeth Warren revealing a test that
supposedly showed that she was Native
American only to show that she is
significantly less Native American than
a Jeep Grand Cherokee were you a person
who thought you know maybe we finally
reached the summit of ridiculousness
with Elizabeth Warren claiming that she
was a member of the Cherokee Nation when
in fact Elizabeth Warren is whiter than
this piece of paper did you think well
you ain't seen nothing yet
it's 2018 gang boom so President Trump
leads off this morning and he had a
bunch of tweets about Elizabeth Warren
we'll get to those in just a second but
we begin we begin with the President of
the United States who's decided that he
doesn't like stormy Daniels anymore
our producer Sonya is down with illness
but we'll make a Taylor Swift reference
for her here it turns out they are never
ever ever getting back together so here
is what happened there's a lawsuit that
stormy Daniels had filed against the
President of the United States who's
always a frivolous stupid lawsuit
anybody with a law degree knew this and
there was a suit in which she sued him
for defamation after he tweeted that she
was engaged in a total con job and she
he tweeted a sketch years later about a
non-existent man a total con job playing
the fake news media for fools this is
when she claimed that she was stalked by
a guy who was sent by Trump and she sued
him for defamation okay that's not
information she's a public figure
defamation is knowing and knowingly and
maliciously attacking someone false
information it's knowing and malicious
is the standard for public figures it
wasn't knowing and it wasn't malicious
it was just basically free speech in him
giving an opinion but she sued him for
defamation and then it was thrown out
the case was thrown out and here's what
the judge wrote the court agrees with
mr. Trump's argument because the tweet
in question constitutes rhetorical
hyperbole normally associated with
politics and public discourse in the
United States the First Amendment
protects this type of rhetorical
statement not only that the judge ruled
that stormy Daniels now had to pay
Trump's legal fees ouch
so the presidents of the United States
had a had a response on Twitter remember
this is an office once occupied by
Abraham Lincoln George Washington Ronald
Reagan here's the President of the
United States official statement on his
Twitter account quote Federer the judge
throws out stormy Daniels the suit
versus Trump Trump is entitled to full
legal fees great now I can go after her
his face and her third-rate liar in the
great state of Texas she would confirm
the letter she signed she knows nothing
about me a total con well that's one way
to step on a news cycle so we could have
done an entire week of Elizabeth Warren
now we will do an
entire week of the presidents of the
United States calling a woman he once
had sex with horseface yeah so that's a
thing now
a couple of different things to note
here first of all if you had to sum up
this entire is entire news cycle in one
meme it would be President Trump as The
Lone Ranger silver would be horse face
stormy Daniels and Tonto would be
Elizabeth Warren so our artistic
geniuses in the backroom are cooking up
that one right now but with that said is
it good that the President of the United
States calls any woman horse face no
probably not a good thing is it smart
that he calls a woman he once had sex
with horse face well it does call into
judge from it does call into question
his judgment regarding women it's kind
of a weird thing to do like you have sex
with a woman you're not married to and
then you call her horse face is that
more of a rip on her or rip on your
taste because it's kind of weird
also just politically speaking is that
gonna make for a good news cycle that
now we're gonna get media outraged about
Trump calling woman horse face like a
week and a half after the Brett
Kavanaugh saga in which the Left wanted
to launch a war on women and failed is
that gonna be good
no but no one ever accused the president
of not stepping on his own mushroom so
it's really it's it's it's not great
I'll be honest with you I think that
there are flaws in this in this line of
thinking then when the president got up
this morning he thought you know what
I'm gonna tweet about sir--my daniels
and her horse face I hosted other away
didn't I linden linden um yeah not great
not great okay now just from an
objective an objective human point of
view is it hilarious
of course it's hilarious okay we can
appreciate two things at once
Trump when it comes to women is a
garbage human hey I've said this 1
million times because it is 1 million
times true he is not great with women
when I say not great with women I mean
that this is a man who said in the 1970s
that avoiding STDs was his own personal
Vietnam this is a guy who nailed
anything that moved for about 40 years
here and this is it this is a man who is
very lucky they're not lots of little
legitimate Trump's walking around like
Trump
has not been shy about his treatment of
women I mean he was caught on tape in
the last election cycles saying an
Access Hollywood tape that he grabbed
women by their by their hooves so it's
it's it's very it's like there's nothing
shocking here but just from a pure human
point of view are we through the
looking-glass
are we in the middle of idiocracy you
bet your ass little vidi accuracy I mean
my goodness I guess I got to the stables
every morning and they're to his face
horse face and toad from Mario Cart in
American romance that's where we are so
all good stuff the other narrative of
the day is that Elizabeth Warren as
Tonto is not actually Native American so
she claimed that she was Native American
and many many many many many times she
claims that she was Native American in
legal journals she claimed that she was
Native American an award that you want
from University of Pennsylvania Law
School she claimed that she was Native
American in a story that she told over
and over and over a romantic story Romeo
and Juliet story about her mother a
native Amer approve American woman
wandering the plains who met her father
and her father brought her home but the
in-laws were racist racist and said you
can't bring home that Native American
woman you can't bring home that that
Indian get out of here and then
apparently her parents eloped and they
had a beautiful romance from there on
and well it turns out that Elizabeth
Warren is not in fact Native American
but it was funny to watch as the
narrative turned yesterday so yesterday
Elizabeth Warren started this whole
thing off by releasing a video of her
and her family members talking about how
Native American she was and here was
what the video sounded like this isn't
just about casual racism war hoops and
tomahawk chops and Native communities
have faced discrimination neglect and
violence for generations and Trump can
say whatever he wants about me but
mocking Native Americans or any group in
order to try to get at me
that's not what America stands for some
people have questioned my heritage in my
family history maybe they do it to
insult me maybe they do it to distract
from the kinds of changes I'm fighting
for and the kind of change I'm trying to
bring to Washington maybe they do it
because they think politics is a
bloodsport but my parents were real
people the love they shared the struggle
spanned or the family they built the
story they lived will always be etched
on my heart man and no one not even the
President of the United States don't
ever take it away the story is etched on
her heart edged on her heart and then
she goes to all our family members who
are talking about their Native American
heritage and then she releases a study
and the study shows that she's what
maybe maybe not totally maybe one 1000
24th Native American one 1000 24th
Native American which is just awesome
it's just awesome in every way so she
releases that and watches her tweets
evolve over the course of the day so she
starts off by saying this by the way a
real Donald Trump remember saying on 7 5
July 5th that you'd give a million
dollars to a charity of my choice if my
DNA showed Native American ancestry I
remember and here's the verdict please
send the check to the National
Indigenous Women's Resource Center a
number one that's how he said what he
said is if you prove you're Native
American and then I'll give you a
million bucks
shouldn't prove she was Native American
she proved that she is whiter than any
person the side of marky-mark and then
she continued tweeting but watch our
tweets evolve and IWR see is a
non-profit working to protect Native
women from violence more than half of
all Native women have experienced sexual
violence and the majority of violent
crimes against Native Americans are
perpetrated by non-natives send them
your one million dollar check Donald
Trump and then she continues along these
lines I took the test and released the
results for anyone who cares to see
because I've got nothing to hide what
are you hiding Donald Trump release your
tax returns or the democratic-led house
will do it for you soon enough
tick-tock mr. president no there's one
of most annoying things on Twitter these
days the tick-tock rutila
well tick-tock and we're ticking down to
something big or it turns down we are
ticking down to you completely
collapsing in on yourself like a dying
star she continues and she says having
some
Rinat problems Donald Trump should we
call for a doctor here's something you
won't forget mr. president you're the
least popular president in modern
history and your allies will go down
hard in the midterm elections 22 days
tick tock tick tock oh god oh god amen
she could but then she concludes I won't
sit quietly for Donald Trump's racism so
I took a test but but DNA and family
history has nothing to do with tribal
affiliation or citizenship which is
determined only only by tribal nations I
respect a distinction and don't list
myself as native in the Senate what
happened like I mean that was a sudden
left turn is like when Michael Scott was
driving on the road and the GPS told him
to drive into the lake that's basically
how that sweet thread went he just he's
talking and she's talking about
yeah I'm Native American and and Native
Americans are great and give us some
money in Native American logic but I'm
not Native American what could have
happened to trigger such a change what
could have happened to Tonto we will
explain in just one second but first
let's talk about your omega-3 levels if
you're experiencing joint pain or
chronic inflammation lack of
concentration weight gain chances are
you're probably one of those folks this
is why you need to try Oh max three
ultra-pure Oh max is offering my
listener 60% off a one-month supply of
ultra-pure plus free shipping and a 60
day money back guarantee so you can try
it if you don't like it then you're not
gonna lose anything you hear all the
hype around omega-3s well now is your
chance to try the purest form of omega-3
on the market go to try Oh max calm /
capiro omega-3 fatty acids they're vital
to your overall health they're
considered a worthwhile pill certainly
by experts they improve mood memory
brain cardiovascular health but a lot of
the top sellers simply are not pure
enough to actually do anything this is
why if you want to feel the benefits you
need to try Oh max three ultra-pure it's
the only game-changing omega-3
supplement on the market 94% pure with a
patented epa to DHA ratio of four-to-one
to fight unwanted joint pain and
inflammation
you know folks in the office have tried
Oh max three and they say that it really
does work go check it out right now also
you can do the freezer test if you take
any other omega-3 and you put it in the
freezer you take it out it's cloudy
because it's not pure Oh max three
soft-shell remains clear because it is
indeed pure ago to try Oh max calm slash
Shapiro to get 60% off a one-month
supply plus free shipping and a 60 day
money-back guarantees he got nothing to
lose
gry oma XCOM / up arrow to get 60% of a
one-month supply plus free shipping and
that 60-day money-back guarantee try o
max calm slash a pair of terms and
conditions do apply
so what could have changed Elizabeth
Warren's mind what could have changed
her mind she was saying very confidently
that she was Native American that she
was Native American and then ulsan well
you know it turns out the tribes get to
decide who's Native American why why
because the Cherokee Nation came out and
said you're not Native American the
chair that now let's be clear about this
the Cherokee Nation does not come out
and make political statements very often
but they sends out their Secretary of
State Chuck Hoskin to issue a statement
he said quote a DNA test is useless to
determine tribal citizenship current DNA
tests do not even distinguish whether a
person's ancestors were indigenous to
North or South America sovereigns tribal
nations set their own legal requirements
for citizenship and while DNA tests can
be used to determine lineage such as
paternity to an individual it is not
evidence for tribal affiliation and then
they continued using a DNA test to lay
claim to any connection to the Cherokee
Nation or any tribal nation even vaguely
is inappropriate and wrong it makes a
mockery out of DNA tests and it's
legitimate uses while also dishonouring
legitimate tribal governments and their
citizens whose ancestors are well
documented and whose heritage is proven
senator warren is undermining tribal
interests with her continued claims of
tribal heritage
ouch-ouch so she just got slammed by the
Cherokee Nation to which she claims
ancestral membership yeah that went
poorly for Elizabeth Warren which is why
she shifted said I'm not claiming that
I'm Native American anymore but I'm a
kind of Native American so give me a
million dollars again I call on the
Trump administration I callin president
from personally signed a nine hundred
dollar check to Elizabeth Warren's
charity of choice because she is 1/1000
24th Native American maybe he should pay
her one one one thousand twenty fourth
of a million dollars that is the amount
to which she is owed so President Trump
was asked about this yesterday and he
basically just missed all of it
who cares
I think you better read it again
I hope she's running for president
because I think she'd be very easy I
hope that she is running I do not think
she'd be difficult at all she'll destroy
the country she'll make our country into
Venezuela with that being said I don't
want to say bad things about it because
I hope she would be one of the people
that would get through the process gonna
be a long process with a Democrat
okay so President Trump he's eager to go
after Elizabeth Warren again I still
think we need the image of him with a
Publishers Clearing House sighs check
handing it sista to to Elizabeth Warren
in order to basically have that image
linked with Elizabeth Warren forever
unfortunately it seems like he's
swiveled and he's less interested in
whether Elizabeth Warren has a
relationship with Tonto and more
interested in whether stormy Daniels is
in fact silver has another way well but
I want to talk a little bit more about
why it's important for Elizabeth Warren
to have maintained her native-american
ancestry point what made her think she
could get away with this so let's talk
about that
here's the thing there's a story that
came out September 1st of this year in
the Boston Globe and it discussed a
serious issue for Elizabeth Warren was
senator Warren actually a professor at
Harvard Law because she claimed Native
American ancestry in other words was she
granted special status that sort of gave
her in an upper hand when it came to her
job at University of Pennsylvania or at
Harvard Law School
well this long article from the Boston
Globe in depth research found that folks
at Harvard said that her Native American
claims had nothing to do with any of
that that her Native American claims had
nothing to do with her actual ability to
be granted a professorship at Harvard
Law School they interviewed some like 31
professors many of whom were on the
admissions committee someone whom I know
people like Charles freed who I had four
contracts he said no when we hired her
it had nothing to do with her claiming
Native American ancestry in fact we
didn't even know that at the time we
assumed she was white and the internal
documents suggested that University of
Pennsylvania treated her as a white
person and so did Harvard Law School
until it became beneficial for them to
claim that she was of minority heritage
for purposes of their diversity
curriculum right they had to claim that
they had a certain number of diverse
professors and so they sort of faked it
and said that she was Native American
but that doesn't mean she got her job
based on Native American Native American
claims
what so with that said why didn't
Elizabeth Warren a month and a half ago
simply say look I was told by my family
members that I had Cherokee ancestry my
mom used to tell me that my uncles and
aunts used to tell me that and because
of that I simply assumed that they all
read I was going to assume that my
relatives were lying to me those were
the stories that I was told growing up I
guess that was wrong and so I never
should have done any of that stuff but
it didn't have any impact on my actual
career trajectory my career trajectory
was gonna be great no matter what and
had nothing to do with those claims so I
apologize to Native Americans for having
taken seriously the stories of my family
without checking them but with that said
to claim that I was a beneficiary of
some sort of affirmative action is
simply untrue but why didn't she do that
well there are two reasons she didn't do
that and both of them are telling reason
number one she figured that she could
get away with pretty much anything
because the media would cover for her
which the media did yesterday there were
headlines in the Daily Beast's saying
Elizabeth Warren proves Native American
ancestry there's a headline over at CNN
Elizabeth Warren provides solid evidence
of Native American ancestry so she
legitimately threw out a study that
showed she was not Native American and
counted on the media to say that the
study showed she was actually Native
American and the media complied for the
first 12 hours and then it all began to
fall apart because people can read and
we don't live in a world where there are
only three networks and three major
newspapers anymore we live in a world
where people can fact check stuff and
that meant that her narrative began to
collapse in on her so she thought she
could get away with it because the media
would cover for her and why not why
wouldn't you think that I mean the media
have covered from the fact that beta
will work in Texas who is being treated
as an Obama esque kennedy-esque
new young figure that that guy was
involved in a DUI when he was 26 that
involved him crossing over a median line
smashing a truck and then trying to flee
from the scene and they're still touting
him as the big new next democratic thing
now listen I'm somebody who's had my
license suspended for driving too fast
I'm obvious about that I was not driving
drunk and I didn't crash into anybody it
was on an empty freeway bado O'Rourke
was driving drunk and hit a guy and then
tried to flee the scene while he was
drunk and the media have basically said
that's a big nothing this is the same
media that said that george w bush's DUI
back in the 1970s should have
qualified him in 2000 from running for
the presidency like two weeks before the
election so Elizabeth Warren had good
cause to think that the media were going
to cover for her no matter what if the
media covered Democrats the way they
cover Republicans half of the candidates
for Congress in this election cycle
would be toast they would be finished if
Bob Menendez in New Jersey would be done
he'd be he honestly he'd be gone Claire
McCaskill in Missouri would be done
Kristin's cinema in Arizona would be
just toast but they are not because
Elizabeth Warren like every other
Democrat knows that there is a grace a
sort of buffer zone that is established
for Democratic candidates and so she can
simply claim Native American ancestry
without any proof and the media will
continue to cover for her as much as
humanly possible right and they they
will just continue to cover for her
endlessly that's the reason number one
that Elizabeth Warren felt comfortable
releasing a study that actually
contradicted her main narrative line
then there is reason number two and this
one goes a little bit deeper for the
Democrats so reason number two we'll get
to in just one second first let's talk
about how you manage your money okay you
need to outsmart average you need be
better than the average investor the
smart way to manage your money is the
folks over at betterment so betterment
has a cutting edge technology combined
with human expertise it's an investment
tool for people who refuse to settle for
average investing their technology is
designed to help you make more from your
investments it's unlimited expert advice
designed to help you make those smart
financial decisions tax efficient
investing strategies that give you an
edge low transparent fees constant
access to information and tools that
allow you to track progress toward your
goals so you can always feel like a
smart savvy investor the reason that you
need betterment is for the same reason
that you are a person you don't need you
don't necessarily have all the time that
you need in order to do all the research
on your own into investing well
betterment helps you do all of that
stuff to an online financial advisor I
have a financial advisor you should have
a financial advisor too and cost should
not be a barrier to getting good
financial advice
well betterment makes sure that you can
get that financial advice with
extraordinarily low cost and all the
information you need
now investment involves risks with
listeners can get up to one year manage
for free for more information visit
betterment comm slash repair that's
betterment com
/ up hero outsmart average again sign up
today and get up to one year managed for
free that is betterment comm slash
Shapiro and again that gets you up to
one year manage for freeze it's a pretty
solid deal for getting good advice on
how exactly you ought to be investing
your money okay so what is the second
reason
what is the second reason that Elizabeth
Warren didn't just come out months ago
and say listen my family got the story
wrong
you know we're I shouldn't have said all
that stuff but I trusted my family my
bad had no impact on my career why
didn't you just say that the second
reason is because identity politics
identity politics is all that matters
the left an Elizabeth Warren knows this
she knows that in a battle between
Elizabeth Warren and Kamala Harris she
comes up short in the minority category
folks in the Democratic Party have
decided that all that matters in the end
is intersectionality how many victim
groups you belong to Elizabeth Warren
only belongs to one purported victim
group she's a white woman and white
women are under a pretty significant
attack by the left right now there was
an article we read last week on this
program an op-ed in the New York Times
talking about how white women were the
serious problem in the United States
Elizabeth Warren is a white woman she
has no intersectional advantage over
cory booker over Kamala Harris over to
vatra k-- claiming minority status
allows her to say that she is part of
the victimized minority in the United
States even though she's led a pretty
easy life it wasn't with Warren went to
Rutgers law school and then she became a
a lawyer and then she became a law
professor at University of Texas at
Austin then University of Pennsylvania
then Harvard Law School she flipped some
houses she's made some money elizabeth
warren is not a person who has endured
tremendous suffering at the hands of the
evil american patriarchy and hierarchy
she has to come up with some story of
victimhood and the easiest way to do
that is to try and connect to your
relatives it's the same routine that
Hillary Clinton did she used to talk
about her parents all the time and how
her parents suffered a lot her mom
particularly was was trod upon as a
woman in the United States because
Elizabeth because it turns out Hillary
didn't have a good victimization story
in the Democratic Party you need a
victimization story in order so that you
can try to lead the charge on behalf of
all the victim groups elizabeth warren
knew that she needed to lead that charge
but she could only do that if she
identified as some form of minority and
the way that she did that is by saying
that she had Native American ancestry
and what group and
has been more put-upon than Native
Americans and so she wouldn't let it go
she wouldn't let it go now it's
backfired on her because you can imagine
how these Democratic debates are gonna
go you're gonna see people like Kamala
Harris
turn to a turn to Elizabeth Warren you
see Deval Patrick cory booker turns to
Elizabeth Warren and suggests that
Elizabeth Warren basically traded on
fake minority heritage in order to try
and score points with the minority base
it's gonna hurt her pretty badly so
Elizabeth Warren actually damaged
herself pretty significantly but that
was basically inevitable because she was
stuck between a rock and a hard place
she's just a white woman running in a
party that doesn't care about white
woman and thinks that white women are
part of the patriarchy and she also
can't claim minority status cuz if she
does she's lying so Elizabeth Warren
shot herself in the foot in a pretty
significant way here and I'm not sure
that she recovers because honesty was
not a priority if she had simply been
honest about all this stuff everything
would have been fine she wasn't and so
things went to hell in a handbasket for
her meanwhile she's not the only
Democrat in turmoil as a story out today
President Trump has raised all ready for
his reelection ancestry his ancestry his
reelection campaign 100 million dollars
in fundraising for his reelection it's
only 2018 according to Greenwich Times
the Greenwich Times President Trump has
topped 100 million dollars in
fundraising for his 20/20 re-election
bid an enormous haul for a president
barely two years into his first term
according to new figures reported by his
2020 campaign Trump pulled in more than
18 million dollars last quarter through
his campaign committee and two joint
fundraising committees with the RNC for
a total of at least 106 million since
January 17 2017 according to his
campaign and federal filings so that's
bad news for Democrats who thought that
Trump would have collapsed at this point
that he would have destroyed himself by
this point Trump can't destroy himself
because nothing you do can destroy a man
who has no character hey president Trump
is not a man of rich character listen I
like a lot of what he does politically
but this is a guy who goes on Twitter
and calls former lovers he had sex with
while he was married horseface okay so
it's gonna be kind of difficult to
destroy that cut and it turns out that
most folks who want to see his
priorities put in place don't care too
much about his character
we've established that character in
American politics is no longer a major
concern obviously and so Trump can raise
as much money as he wants meanwhile
Democrats and Senate races across the
country are having trouble to peyto
O'Rourke acting on the best ideals of
his democratic spread the wealth around
campaign he announced on Monday he is
not going to share any of his 38 million
dollar war chest
even though Democratic bosses want the
cash for more competitive states so beta
O'Rourke is going to lose to Ted Cruz in
Texas in the Senate race latest polls
have him down almost double digits after
the media had been fawning over him the
same way they fawned over Wendy Davis
the former state senator in Texas who
then lost by something like 20 points to
Greg Abbott well now they are for a
governor in Texas they're doing the same
thing with beta O'Rourke beta won't
share the money why would he spread the
wealth around
am I so greedy they don't work it's like
a Republican or something
the Texas Democrat told reporters after
a campaign rally he will not spare any
expense in his own race he plans to
leave all the money he has raised out on
the field ahead of Election Day
O'Rourke raised from July to September
38 point 1 million dollars he says that
he is going to he is not going to
contribute any of that money to other
candidates which is kind of amazing
because honestly if he wants to ensure
his future in the Democratic Party he
really should become a patron of the
Arts right he should be taking that
money and distributing it to more hotly
contested races he's not going to do any
of that so that's a bad story for
Democrats meaning meanwhile Claire
McCaskill is running a very tight race
in Missouri and James O'Keefe the enemy
undercover journalist he's gonna shock
journalists over at project Veritas he's
done some good work before he sends his
workers in T sent some of his folks in
to Claire McCaskill's office and he got
Claire McCaskill's people to acknowledge
that she is campaigning far to the right
of where she actually isn't on the
issues here's some of what that sounded
like
I can tell them because she does support
a semi-automatic firearm
because I won't say someone shouldn't
say I think semi-automatic Ana
semi-automatic rifle bit okay more so
much it's important but she doesn't like
openly go out and support groups like
moms to main action we're just like
other groups that are like related to
that because that couldn't hurt like
people her like her ability to get
elected because people like see that and
they're just like well I don't want to
support her even though like they say
for the same policies um okay so she's
basically been fibbing about her own
positions so Claire McCaskill is in
trouble in Missouri Cristen cinema just
three weeks ago was leading martha
mcsalley in the Arizona Senate race and
now it turns out that all of her past
has come out and Cristen cinema is a
nutcase
so Kyrsten Sinema is the Democratic
nominee in Arizona according to the
Washington Examiner she apparently takes
sorcery very seriously emails obtained
by The Washington Examiner show cinema
was invited to a prominent coven of
feminist witches in Arizona it was
called Pagan cluster to celebrate
International Women's Day and to protest
the war in March of 2003 code pink
protesters were pink obviously enough
and the women in black or black but
cinema encouraged the witches to wear
colorful clothing and come ready to
dance twirl and stay in touch with your
inner creativity and with the earth the
cinema campaign would not say why she
invited the witches or clarify why she
thought members of the occult deserved a
seat at the table during discussions
concerning war and peace the witches in
question it should be noted claimed to
practice only nonviolent magic for the
About section on their web page there is
a peaceful and democratic kind of
sorcery the Pagan cluster focuses on
sharing spiritual insights and
participating in direct democracy their
visions are decidedly liberal many of
their coven quote have roots in the
reclaiming tradition of feminist
witchcraft mmm-hmm cinema also went to
an anti-war rally with pagans later that
year and apparently she talked about
singing and spiraling in the pagans
circle only five rows from the police
line and then the police arrested
everybody so Kyrsten Sinema
yeah just doing yeoman's work on behalf
of her own campaign also it turns out
she organized for the Arizona Alliance
for peace and justice in one email she
urged supporters of the AAA
PJ to dilute to deluge the phone lines
of a radio show hosted by an
unapologetic unconditional supporter of
Israeli policy so Kyrsten Sinema is
basically toast in that Senate race as
well Democrats radicalism is the major
issue here and all they have is
President Trump which is why it's not
good that the President of the United
States goes around calling women
face I mean really this will get to more
of that in just one second the
Democratic response to all of this plus
a kind of shocking story Carter Paige is
now suing the folks over at fusion GPS
we'll get to all of that in just second
first I need to talk to you about
something that has really made my back
feel better so I work out a lot I mean
look at this chiseled body I work out a
lot but that also means that I sometimes
get lower back pain particularly like
after lifting heavy objects I get lower
back pain and that was why I was so
excited to hook up with the folks over
at Teeter the teeter inversion table is
awesome they use gravity and your own
body way to decompress your spine
relieve pressure on your discs and
surrounding nerves in fact my personal
trainer is a guy who you know he's in
incredible shape he's in his early 50s
he's an just unbelievable shape like the
shape of a 30 year old but he started
having significant neck and back pain
and he started using the teeter
inversion table to relieve that pain as
well they thought he's gonna need
surgery he may not need surgery you know
based on the relief of the pain part
which is due to the teeter inversion
table decompressing on a teeter
inversion table for a few minutes a day
is a great addition to anyone's daily
routine to maintain a healthy spine and
active lifestyle without the pain it
decompresses my my spine it's good for
the shoulders now there are some
products that I talked about that I use
a lot this is definitely one of them the
teeter inversion table is just awesome
over three million people have put their
trust in teeter and they're the only
inversion table brand that has both been
both safely certified by UL laboratories
and FDA registered as a class 1 medical
device him right now they're offering a
great deal for my listeners for a
limited time and get the brand new 2019
Teeter Fit spine inversion table model
with bonus accessories and a free pair
of gravity boots so you can invert at
home or take the boots with you to the
gym the regular price is $499 for 349
bucks a saving of one hundred and fifty
dollars at teeter comm / Ben you also
get free shipping free returns a 60-day
money back guarantee so there is
absolutely no risk to you to try it out
remember you can only get the new 20 19
fit spine inversion table plus a free
pair of gravity boots by going to Teeter
calm / Ben that's te e ter dot-com / Ben
for that special deal go check it out
right now it really is a fantastic
product okay now if you wanna listen to
the rest of today's show and more jokes
about horses and Tonto then what you
really need to do is go over to daily
wire calm right now and subscribe when
you do you get all sorts of goodies you
get the rest of the show live the rest
of Clavin stroll addresses no Liz's show
live when you get our annual you get
that that's $99 a year cheaper than the
monthly you got this the leftist tears
hot or cold tumbler much-sought-after
much discussed but never duplicated also
you get access to all of our hosts when
you want to ask them questions like
today 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m.
Pacific it's time for our next episode
of the conversation when Andrew Clavin
will be taking your questions and
answering them live on air it's hosted
by Alecia Krause and you'll get a full
hour of Drew's wisdom guaranteed to
produce leftist tears plus the light
that emerges from his bald shiny dome
will illuminate your name as always this
episode will be free for everybody to
watch on Facebook and YouTube only
subscribers can ask the question so go
check that out plus more goodies coming
up this Wednesday October 16th 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific don't mix don't
miss our next episode of daily wire
backstage with god-king jeremy boring
myself andrew Clavin Michael Mills and
Alicia Kraus we'll be taking questions
but only from daily wire subscribers to
make sure to become one today
I mean look at the amount of content
we're putting out for you people what do
I have to do to get you to subscribe
just go do it already come on you listen
every day and lazy bums just go just go
subscribe just do it and get this again
look at this it's magical the leftist
year's hot or cold tumblr you will love
it
go check all that I plus subscribe at
YouTube subscribe over at iTunes we have
great Sunday specials coming up I can't
wait to announce next week's guest
because it really is great we have like
the next several weeks with unbelievable
guests we have great guests last week
with chocolate willing we have a bunch
that are just amazing coming out go
check that out leave us a 5 star review
on iTunes if you know what's good for
you go check that out right now we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so with all of this said with all of
this said the economy continues to do
well this was such a good news cycle it
really was it was such a good news cycle
the economy was doing great the new jobs
numbers are just terrific not only that
we have the highest federal collection
of income taxes in history in 2018
though the if you just look at the
numbers we are collecting more income
taxes than ever before even though we
have lower income tax rates than we did
last year why because supply-side
economics works when the economy grows
then the government actually takes in
more taxes than if the economy is
stagnant and we have higher tax rates
the economy has been going great guns
under President Trump we'll get to the
deficit in a second which is not quite
as good but this is a very good news
cycle for President Trump so in the last
three weeks he got a Supreme Court
justice and watch the left kill
themselves over Cavanaugh he got
Elizabeth Warren in one of the great
unforced political blunders of my
lifetime releasing a report saying she
was Native American when she is less she
is less Indian than actual people from
India like actual people from India have
more Native American blood than
Elizabeth Warren does it's an amazing
thing and with that said president Trump
decides to step on himself with stormy
Daniels and calling people horseface
this is the only line of attack that
Democrats have is just attacks on
President Trump and so this is what
they're ratcheting up Nancy Pelosi who's
looking at a bad Senate map right now
she's trying to suggest that President
Trump is now in the pay of the Saudis
that the reason that President Trump
hasn't been harsher on the Saudi
government with regard to their murder
of Jamal khashoggi their alleged murder
of Jamal Kannagi an American resident
who was a critic of the Saudi regime and
also a fan of the Muslim Brotherhood she
says the reason Trump hasn't been
harsher is cuz maybe he's being paid off
by the Saudis in terms of Saudi Arabia I
think that was I've always wondered why
he went there as the first country to
visit outside of the United States of
course as president of the United States
all the other presidents back to Ronald
Reagan went to to Canada or to one to
Mexico George W Bush so in our
hemisphere were there many friends and
allies we could have gone to so there
was I was always suspicious that there
was some kind of a financial transaction
involved there whether for his business
says whatever good luck with this line
of attack it's it's pretty crazy that
the that Democrats think the only way
that they're gonna be able to win
elections is by simply throwing out
unverified and unverifiable information
like this but it shows how desperate
they are which is why again unforced
errors are the biggest problem for the
Trump administration they've always been
the biggest problem for the Trump
administration here's here's I think the
rule in American politics right now
whoever shuts up first wins really
because this is just it's the worst
tennis match ever right if you if you
watch tennis players you very often you
will see that sometimes the best
strategy is just get the ball over the
net because sooner or later somebody is
gonna smack the ball into the net and
then you win basically there's a great
line which which comedian is it I think
it's Mitch Hedberg is that that the name
of the comedian and so he has a line he
says no matter how good the problem I
have with tennis is no matter how good I
get I'm never better than the wall well
that's that's essentially what's
happening in American politics right now
if you are the wall you win if you are
the wall you wouldn't that's all if you
are the person who just sits there and
lets the other side bang its head
against you you win if you're the person
who commits unforced errors you lose the
Democrats have been committing unforced
error after unforced error here and
that's why it would be great if the
president would just stop but again I
guess we're gonna have an entire news
cycle now about horseface doesn't hurt
Trump in any serious way not really but
it does jazz up the Democrats again it
reminds them how much they hate
President Trump when he goes away it's
hard for them to talk about this as much
nobody cares but with that said Trump
Trump gun Trump that's just the way that
it goes now the Trump also comes along
with the benefit of Trump right there's
always a good side to what Trump is and
a bad side to what Trump is so the same
guy who calls his former lovers
horseface is the same fellow who's
actually trying to stop these immigrant
caravans that have been traveling from
places like Honduras so President Trump
on Tuesday threatened to withdraw
funding an aide from Honduras if it does
not stop a caravan of people that head
is heading to the United States Trump
said the United States has strongly
informed the presidents of Honduras that
if the large caravan of people heading
to the US has not stopped and brought
back to Honduras no more money or aid
will be given to Honduras effective
immediately
up to three thousand migrants cross from
Honduras into Guatemala on
on a trek northward after a standoff
with police in riot gear and warnings
from Washington the migrants should not
try to enter the United States illegally
and then the crowd more than doubled in
size and they do this they do this March
every year where people are sent up from
Latin America through Central America
and to the United States border Trump
threatenings withdraw aid from countries
that don't stop this seems not
completely unreasonable to me with that
said he should be threatening aid to
Saudi Arabia as well based on their
human rights violations and frankly any
country that commits human rights
violations in the way that Saudi Arabia
has I'm not sure why we should be
funding those countries especially when
we have the capacity to do much more
direct damage to Iran through sanctions
and through military know-how then the
Saudis do I mean the Saudis basically
are there because we let them be there
in any case the the other big story of
the day is that Carter page is now suing
the DNC so according to the Daily Caller
former Trump campaign associate Carter
page has filed a defamation lawsuit
Monday against the DNC and its law firm
which commissioned the infamous steel
dossier page filed the suit in federal
court in Oklahoma against the DNC the
law firm Perkins Coie and two of its
partners mark Elias and Michael Sussman
now you remember what happened with
cutter Page the accusation from the
Republicans that Carter page was a
low-level foreign policy aide for
President Trump was basically hamstrung
by the DNC he was targeted for
destruction by the DNC working hand in
glove with law enforcement members of
the FBI and the Obama administration the
goal being to get a FISA warrant against
him and that would somehow damage the
Trump campaign that's basically the
accusation and to to support that
accusation there are a couple of pieces
of evidence one Carter page still has
not been arrested for all the attempts
to get Carter page nobody's actually
gotten Carter page on anything he's not
been arrested he's not been tried no
charges have been brought against him so
maybe this was all a setup point number
two is that there are heavy ties between
the the fusion GPS firm that was hired
by the DNC to do opposition research
which included some kind of page
material in the steel dossier and the
DNC and the FBI and those ties have been
revealed over time and they are
bothersome they're quite bothersome
they're quite troubling page is he filed
that lawsuit and Perkins Coie is the
firm that hired fusion gps the
opposition researcher than
stated Donald Trump's links to Russia
Elias who's one of the lawyers over at
Perkins Coie was Perkin quite main
contact to fusion GPS it was founded by
three former Wall Street Journal
reporters as part of its 1 million
dollar project fusion GPS hired
Christopher Steele to conduct the
investigation now what's fascinating
about this lawsuit is that lawsuits
sometimes are designed for victory and
sometimes lawsuits are designed for
discovery in other words in the process
of doing a lawsuit you can ask bunch a
lot of questions to the person that you
are suing and they are forced to give up
documents on those topics so Carter
pager obviously wants to dig deep into
what the DNC was doing with Perkins Coie
what they were doing with fusion GPS it
also opens him up to discovery as well
so in response you could see the DNC
asking for materials on Carter pages
relationship with the Trump
administration in Russia for Carter page
to launch the loss unless it's really
ill founded suggests that Carter page
doesn't have a lot to hide but he thinks
the DNC does have a lot to hide that's
damaging stuff obviously before the DNC
if that is true again Carter page has
been sort of the the main linchpin of a
lot of Democratic efforts to paint
collusion between Donald Trump and the
Russian government in 2016 and so far no
hard evidence has been brought out to
prove any of that stuff to prove any of
that stuff so that is a story that we're
gonna watch as it unfolds now in other
news that I think is not as good the
budget deficit is the highest that it's
been in years and I hear I have to ding
Republicans so we've heard for a lot of
years that Republicans care about budget
deficits we kept hearing that Barack
Obama was blowing out the debt which he
was it's up to about 21 trillion dollars
now it's unsustainable and that's only
the debt that we know about basically
there's bunch of unfunded liabilities
that put our actual total debt at many
multiples of 20 trillion dollars
unfunded liabilities for which we'll
have to raise taxes or blow out
inflation but the US budget deficit is
expanding Republicans have not been
fiscally responsible President Trump has
not been fiscally responsible
he's been around taxes he's been good on
regulations he's been very very very bad
on spending according to CNBC the US
federal budget deficit rose in fiscal
year 2018 to the highest level in six
years as spending climbed the Trump
administration said Monday the deficit
jumped 779 billion 113 billion dollars
or 17% higher than the previous fiscal
period according to a statement from
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin it's
larger than any years since 2012
when it topped one trillion dollars the
budget shortfall rose to three point
nine percent of u.s. gross domestic
product that despite the fact we are now
taking in more money than any time in
American history from income tax the
problem we have in this country is not a
taxing problem it is a spending problem
and government is addicted to spending
and nobody's gonna stop it because no
one has an interest in actually stopping
the spending Americans like the idea of
spending less until you actually ask
them what sorts of programs they wish to
see cut at which point they get quite
skittish very very skittish about doing
any sorts of real cuts at all federal
revenues rose slightly by fourteen
billion dollars after Republicans
chopped tax rates for corporations and
individuals outlays climbed by one
hundred and twenty seven billion dollars
including a spike in defense spending as
well as increases for Medicaid Social
Security and disaster relief so that is
not exactly fiscal discipline we have no
party in the United States that stands
for fiscal discipline that needs to stop
this is bad whether it is Republicans or
whether it is Democrats it is just bad
stuff all the way around there's nothing
good happening here we need to get that
under control if President Trump wants
to win a second term I would suggest
that we start talking in serious fashion
about those deficits at some point that
the the burden comes due okay time for a
few things that I like and then we will
do some things that I hate so things
that I like today mark Levins dad writes
books and he wrote a children's book
that's really great I bought it for my
kids and it's great it reminds kids that
the police can actually be your friends
despite all of the coverage by the by
the media policemen are generally doing
a great job and I say that in spite of
the fact that there are some policemen
who are doof's right I told you a story
last week about a doof policeman who
pulled us over while we were in a police
escort in Detroit but the police overall
do a fantastic job they do a fantastic
job keeping us safe and appreciating the
members of our police is deeply
necessary Jack Levin the father of Mark
Levin wrote this and Mark I think does
something really sweet here by by
pushing his dad's books III think that
that's just a great thing that mark does
I'm a big Mark Levin fan and supporter
you should check it out our police by
Jack Levin go check that out right now
ok other things that I like so this is
pretty funny last week
there was a song that I played on the
show by a young woman of the left her
name was Lindsay lab Stewart it was a
feminist song in which she claims that
women can't do anything in the United
States but men can do anything that they
want and shouldn't be scared of false
rape accusations well that has prompted
a conservative blogger named Kylie
simple to write and perform her own
version of the song I don't know so just
like me so there's a better message it's
a better message then women are deeply
victimized every single day in the
United States and men shouldn't worry
about their victimization at the hands
of women who lie sometimes or who rinse
remember sometimes this is a much better
message because turns out you know it's
a bad message a better message than the
Democratic message the Left message they
are not a victim and that you're in
control of your own life in a free
country there's a fascinating study we
talked about it last week this hidden
tribe study was the one that said 80% of
Americans hate political correctness
that same study showed a massive gap
between the left and the right on one
particular issue whether people can
succeed on their own merits in the
United States 86 percent of people call
themselves progressive said that you are
not free to succeed on your own merits
in the United States only 2% of people
on the right thought that you're not
able to succeed on your own merits in
the United States which one do you think
is a more inspiring message likely to
lead to the success of individuals
certainly the conservative message okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
so alec baldwin now apparently has a
talkshow
I guess on ABC which is pretty
incredible the man just keeps failing up
right he was on MSNBC he lost his talk
show on MSNBC that couldn't support
ratings but they thought okay well put
him on ABC and that will fix things
well one of the things that he said over
the past week is that he's horrified
President Trump as president which is
kind of amazing coming from a guy who
left a message on his daughter's
answering machine talking about how she
was a little pig and how terrible she is
again I understand people having
character quibbles with the presidents
of the United States and serious
character questions about the presidents
of the United States I certainly do but
I do not understand people in Hollywood
suddenly finding their moral scruples
when it comes to presidents after they
spent years preparing the way playing
fluffer for Bill Clinton but here is
Alec Baldwin I mean to me every day I
wake up I still am horrified and I feel
like I'm in some dream that Trump is the
President of the United States I can't
even move can't even say it
okay well the screen is amazing when you
shut that idiot up this is amazing
according to Nielsen the premiere is on
ABC right not on it not on MSNBC or a
cable network on ABC the premiere of his
ABC talk show brought in 2.2 million
total viewers with an anaemic 0.4 rating
and the advertiser coveted 18 to 49
demographic okay let me give you a by
way of contrast hey by way of contrast
he's on ABC a network my Fox Sunday show
okay my Fox election special last week
it elite before son dicks I think the
ratings aren't out yet
the week before Sunday it brought in 1.8
million I nearly matched his ratings on
Fox News on a Sunday night during Sunday
Night Football
hey he's on ABC and he couldn't get any
ratings
he keeps failing up he keeps failing up
you know there's a market for it's it's
really amazing when you think about it
there is not a single Trump forget Trump
supporting Trump curious you know
there's not even anybody who's mildly
positive toward Trump even when he does
good things on network TV and yet they
keep going back to the same old horses
who keep falling down dead in the
ratings and so Alec Baldwin keeps
getting jobs even though the guy can't
draw flies except if he's on another
show like 30 rock or SNL pretty amazing
all of this works okay well we will be
back here tomorrow with all of the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018